hey what's up guys my name is the chana
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we talked about transforms we
added them to our 2d renderer check out
that video if you haven't already and
now that we can actually position these
things anywhere in our screen Annina
inside our kind of level and also set
random sizes to it the next logical step
is to take a look at textures and how we
can actually render these as texture
quads because at the moment all we can
do really is set a different color for
them and whilst that's kind of cool in
here you can have this little game with
no textures and just colors and you can
still do a lot without obviously in kind
of the real world we want to extend this
engine so that it supports textures
especially since the engine does support
textures is just the renderer doesn't
yet so what we'll do today is kind of
discuss textures how we can set them up
for our renderer and yeah we'll just add
that in and make it work but first I
want to give a huge thank you of course
to all the patrons that made this series
possible page when icon for saturated
Shona is the best place to help support
this series and my channel and
everything that I'm doing here if you
guys aren't interested in this 2d stuff
you want to kind of progress to 3d and
take a look at that I do have like a
full 3d renderer going on in that hazel
developer brass with like a viewer layer
so that you can control like textures
models all that fun stuff and in fact I
do want to make more videos in the
future
regarding specifically what I'm doing to
that development branch just so that you
guys get a little bit more insight into
that on patreon as well have also got
exclusive videos just detailing where
this series is kind of going what I'm
doing what's plan for the next episodes
I also show stuff from the Hazel's
development branch such as
multi-threading and all of that stuff
that I'm currently working on as
exclusive videos so definitely check
that out if you're interested and help
support this series okay so textures
where shall we begin with that so this
was the current set up that we left off
in the last episode we can now position
these which is a lovely what I'm gonna
do now is extend a drop quad if we look
at this function
extent draw quad essentially do not just
take in a color but also take the NA
texture and that's pretty easy to do
I'll duplicate both of these functions
instead of color will simply take you
in Texas this will be a comp rev texture
too deep and then we'll just have
texture over here will include texture
and then I'm gonna of course copy this
and replace it with this and that's
pretty much it as far as the functions
go same exact functions to your 3d
position and then we have our texture
here what I'll do is copy these and then
come over here into the CBP file paste
them in and just implement these
functions like this also grab this
render rotary namespace of course pull
that in and get rid of the static
keyword okay cool so we have these
functions now similarly how we did with
this draw quad our kind of 2d or our
back to draw quad will actually call the
vector a drop quad so what we'll do is
initialize that with zero and then just
pass in the texture there okay and now
we have this this is what we're gonna be
working with now initially I'm gonna
copy and paste everything that drawcord
actually has because that's pretty much
what we need to deal with except instead
of us setting a float for color we're
actually going to set a texture now this
is also where this becomes a little bit
interesting and you might want to do it
differently it's useful I will say and
in fact some people like doing this you
can actually have both so you can have a
color and a texture and what happens is
they get multiplied together inside your
fragment shader so what that means is
that you can basically set the color to
white if you just want the texture
normally but if you want to like darken
the texture like faded out or something
like that you know so you can kind of
fade it in over time you can just have
you know that white color and then it
maybe set its alpha accordingly so you
can have like the Alpha animate from 0
to 1 and thus it'll kind of fade in we
can have it fade from black if you
animate the color from like you know 0
all channels all the way to 1 on all
channels or you can tint it red by
having more in the red channel that you
guys kind of get the point there's a lot
you can actually do here if that's the
direction you want to go in so I'm
probably gonna have a function like that
in the future where you could probably
have both a texture and a color tint
applied to it that's also totally
reasonable it's also like a nothing that
you could do
future to extend this is you could
actually have a class or a struct that
represents actually renderable like a
quad so in other words we don't have any
kind of data structures right what we're
doing right now is we're simply every
time we want to draw a quad we have to
specify the position the size of the
texture you know the color that stuff
that's all kind of just parameterised
that's what that's what gets fed into
the actual renderer to D functions but
what you might want to do is actually
create a renderable 2d or something like
that or a quad struct or class inside
your actual engine code base and then
what you can do is if you want to create
that and handle that kind of on the game
side you can be like okay well I've got
my quad and then if I need to like set
its position or whatever I just have to
set the position inside the struct I can
set the color I can set the texture I
can do whatever I want with that and
then when it comes to render I just
passed the renderer of the quad and
because it's of course and knowing type
to the renderer it just gets it and it
gets all the information out this is a
different way of organizing things you
can do that in practice I I don't think
I like doing that the reason is that the
reason is that I think that having like
too many types we'll say in the renderer
and dealing all that stuff just makes
things unnecessarily complicated there's
nothing at all from stopping there's
nothing at all to stopping the game like
side of things from actually creating a
quad struct so if you want you know
inside sandbox 2d or inside your game
you can create a quad struct or a quad
class or whatever or a rectangle class
that has all of that stuff in it like
there's no reason not to do that if
that's the way that you want to go and
then when it comes time to actually
render this you just you know access all
of the different members so quad
opposition quad sighs what texture
whatever right or if you don't want to
do that you can just write another kind
of function if you really want to still
inside your game layer that's just like
you know draw quad and then that will
take in a quarter and then that will
call render a 3d draw cord with kind of
you know quad position quad dot size etc
right so you can do it that way me kind
of looking at the
I don't want to I don't really want to
introduce my own kind of renderable to a
quad kind of class inside the actual
renderer I want to keep it simple and
just have it parameterised like this you
know I have done that in the past with
other engines and projects that I've
worked on I don't really see a reason
off the top of my head right now to do
this I haven't really thought about it
much longer than this cameras been
rolling further so you know maybe I'll
change my mind in the future who knows
especially if someone gives me a good
argument but yeah right right now I just
feel like position size texture keep it
nice and simple Jordan have like a bunch
of types because then that becomes a
little bit more complicated right you
suddenly have to create a little quad
struct instance whenever you want to
make something and that just makes the
code a little bit more bloated which is
something that I like to avoid um anyway
color tinting all of this kind of stuff
yeah well we'll take a look at that
potential it's not really particularly
hard to do and also kind of create some
cool effects without much work so we
might take a look at that but first
let's just get those textures in and
implemented so we'll get rid of color
for now and see how we can just render a
texture alright so coming back into here
I'm just gonna get rid of color what we
want to do basically is bind that extra
silk it will still keep the transform
and then we'll just do texture bind here
with the arrow of course and that's
pretty much it
right so if we look at the shader that
we want to be using it is basically
identical to the flat color shader right
the only difference is that the vertex
shader is identical the only difference
here is that it well it's almost
identical it has a texture coordinate
which is passes to the fragment shader
and then we sample from a texture of
course instead of just having that color
there so that's kind of I guess what
we're dealing with no we should probably
get rid of all these as well from 3d
render we haven't looked at that yet
anyway
maybe I'll let you guys do that by a
pull requests so basically that's it
right the only kind of thing that we
need to worry about is this you texture
you know home this is something that
absolutely needs to be set somewhere so
that's pretty easy to do there or we
also have to load the
obviously so what I'll do is we have our
flat color shader
I'm gonna copy that and I'm gonna add
the extra shadow we'll have that happen
over here so sdata
texture shader and then this will be
texture dot GLSL now we need to
obviously set that uniform so we all
have to extend the shader API a little
bit as well so we'll bind an humble do a
set int and then this will be you on
score texture we'll set that to zero so
that's basically saying that the texture
slot that that sample is going to be
sampling from will be texture slot zero
which is kind of our default slot you
can see that if we bind this sorry for
mine the texture and we don't give it a
slot that default slot is zero so that
is why we're setting 0 over here all
right set int obviously doesn't exist
let's make it exist so we'll have a
stats the insert function which just
takes in an int value over here I'll
quickly grab this and go over to OpenGL
shader and implement it so we have F of
what second override I'll copy this part
of it and then go back to our CPP file
we have set by three I will make a set
int function and then that will just
call upload uniform int name and die
okay cool so there we go we've got that
now back inside our render hid that
should be it so now what happens is well
before what we were doing was of course
binding this color shader and setting
the view projection we have to do that
now for both so if we come down over
here in to begin scene we also need to
have this texture shader and then set
its view projection right and then once
we've done that over here what we bind
Mikola shader and we do the rendering
instead of binding it here we find the
texture shader instead okay and then we
said of course the texture shaders mat
for that's it right so we should now be
able to render textured quads
really simple stuff so what we'll do is
we'll come over here I think the sandbox
app had the original textures that we
tried out so we have like the kernel
ogre and
just a normal alpha texture let's just
go with the normal kind of oil and I
call it alpha Tetris a checkerboard
texture if we go
where was it we loaded it somewhere here
probably there it is I'll just copy this
that's not our checkerboard texture I'll
make a hazel
raft hazel texture texture today em
pulls checkerboard texture and then
inside the CPP file when we inside out
on attach layer while we're doing
absolutely nothing yet we'll do that
checkerboard texture what's going on
here that looks fine and then we'll set
that equal to texture 2d create okay it
looks pretty good to me and then coming
down over here what I'll do is I will
pull draw quad let's just well okay for
the time being I'm gonna just render
this right in the middle well I guess we
should have a little bit of an offset
just to test with that even works maybe
I'll push it up a little bit I'll have
it as point 525 and then of course
instead of color I will have this
checkerboard texture which it still
thinks is a low case so let's just
compile this box I think it's very
confused as to what's going on and of
course a compulsively it's just Visual
Studio B weird as usual um yeah let's
just run this program hopefully we get
our check about texture being drawn okay
cool so we just get a great flat color
now I know exactly why does this happen
it doesn't take too long to work out
especially reflecting on how everything
else is drawn but I'm gonna show you
guys my kind of debug process for
something like this so whenever I get a
textured roaring it's clearly bound this
is not black meaning the texture slot
Chloe has data also this gray is
probably the exact grey that we actually
have in our checkerboard texture if I go
back over here let's just stop this and
go into our textures look a checkerboard
so that gray that you saw rendering
there is probably this great here so
clearly something's happening it's
actually if we go over here LS curative
properties it's probably this pixel is
being rendered here
so clearly something's going on well the
first thing I'm suspicious of
immediately is the texture coordinates
easy to check that out I'm gonna go and
instead of outputting the texture I'm
just gonna output the texture
coordinates
so I'll set color equal to the vet for
the text core so I'm sending them for
the RG for the red and green channels
and then I'll have the earth of the blue
and then one for the Alpha so let's see
what those texture coordinates are set
to and of course as I thought the
texture coordinates are wrong they just
flat read whereas of course they should
be a gradient going from zero to one so
we should see a gradient from black to
red along the x-axis on the bottom here
and from black to green on the y-axis
and of course somewhere here we'll have
like a mix and yellow and stuff like
that so that's not what we're seeing
which means the texture coordinates are
wrong why the texture coordinates wrong
well if we go into render A to D then
you can see that of course we're not
actually setting any types of waters at
all this this kind of vertex buffer does
does not have texture coordinates it's
just got texture positions so we need to
set those off so this bottom-left
becomes zero zero as far as - corners go
this is the right side of the course
that becomes one and zero that is the
top right I believe so that's one one
and then of course the what is that
that's the top left that's zero and then
one
alright cool so there we go we have our
technical ordinance now we need to add
them to the vertex buffer layout which
is really simple we're just API of
course we just do float - and then a
text cord just gonna be anything really
okay and then that's it I think that we
have size of square vertices here so we
should just see and in fact this was
already sized appropriately for those
texture coordinates because I think I
copied it from sandbox app everything
looks good now if we run this we should
see those texture coordinates being
visualized because that's where we left
our shader all right and as you can see
that's exactly what I was talking about
we have black to red black to gray to
black to yellow basically you know all
that axes here so these texture
coordinates are working correctly so now
if we take a look at our shader and we
change it back to the what it was before
like this then we should see I'll check
about texture hopefully being rented and
as you can see it is there it is okay
cool so now what I'll do just to make
this a little bit more interesting
I'm gonna scale it up a ton so that it
kind of acts like a background so what
I'll do here is basically well I'll keep
the position like this still say zero
zero but in this background I'm gonna
just scale it up so I'll make it like
well let's just make this like 10 to
begin with because of course we can zoom
out a camera so this is not gonna be
like a perfect background or anything
like that I just want to make it bigger
really that's what I'm doing if I was
actually trying to set this as a
background I probably do it differently
but this should basically give us that
same effect all right cool so there we
have it it's huge
we can't see anything behind it at all
that's where we get to test out our
other parameter now if I did kind of
draw her first I probably see if last as
an it would be behind everything but I
don't want to do that I still wanted to
or at last but I just want to check this
out so I'll set my I'll push this back
so I'll set the Z coordinate here to
zero one which should push it back and
thus it should be behind everything else
let's test that out and of course we get
nothing because that's pretty typical
the reason that probably happens is will
happen in this case is because we
probably aren't even doing any kind of
depth testing let me take a look at
what's going on inside maybe OpenGL
context or I think more likely this
stuff would be inside renderer dot CPP
so we do run a command in Myint registry
in it ready for many of what is that to
render api yet ok so inside there okay
we've been able to blend so we're gonna
enable some other things we're gonna
enable something called GL depth test so
what this does is basically enables
depth testing so that you will actually
test whether or not a given pixel is
supposed to be behind a pixel or in
front and if it's in front it'll write
into the color buffer if it's not in
front then by default using the default
depth testing function it will just
discard it so it's important that we're
also clearing that depth buffer which we
are and now that we've been able dit we
should hopefully see everything else our
blue and red quads rendering on top of
our checkerboard background but of
course we don't which means there are
some other
pieces to this puzzle which I'm not
seeing so let's go back to render 2d and
see what's going on okay so actually
this should be a negative 0.1 because
I've been Jail does use a right-handed
coordinate system which now that I'm
actually visualizing it does mean that
negative values go yep there we go
negative values actually come out of the
screen so that's why that is the case so
coordinate systems like right-handed
coordinate systems left-handed
coordinate systems that kind of stuff we
should probably talk about in the future
make a note of that because it's not
something that I even considered it's
easy to kind of forget but it's super
important of course so here we have it
we've got our checkerboard background
we've got this rendered being rendered
here which looks pretty cool you can see
that the checkerboard even those being
blown up quite a lot is super sharp
that's because we're using nearest
filtering so yeah that's that's pretty
good the other thing that we could do
that we now that we've kind of blown up
blowing this up to such a large scale is
actually have some fun with the scale of
the texture itself so in other words
what's happening right now is that
everything's like the texture cornice
remaining between 0 & 1 which is fine
but it means that the texture gets
scaled up the texture becomes larger
what we actually could do is multiply
these texture coordinates by like 10 for
example I'll just do that in the
fragment shader just to make this easier
and then you can see what that does is
it makes solder all the squares in the
checkerboard texture a lot smaller we
actually get like a higher resolution
texture and they're weighted that and
the reason that that works is because
our rapping word which I'm actually
surprised that just worked it looks like
everything set up correctly we got
nearest filtering by default and rap by
default as well if a good OpenGL texture
we're not setting our rapping motor at
all but you can see that our
magnification filter here is Kjell
nearest and the other parameter that
we're setting which is an even a pound
you know is something called texture rap
SMT which basically defines how that
texture actually gets rap so what
happens if we exceed that 0 to 1 texture
coordinate system so by default we've
got it set to repeat I think that's what
I've been GL sets the two
if you don't set it all so SMT is what
we should have here but if we were to do
something like GL clamp through edge or
something like that then what would
happen instead is instead of repeating
that texture instead of tiling it
essentially we would just basically
repeat that edge pixel infinitely so you
can see that what happens here is we
have our kind of original texture but
then the very last pixel here which is
that edge pixel that just gets repeated
all the way across so that's obviously
not what we want
by default we do want that kind of well
for this scenario we definitely want
repeat because that means that it's
child and that's kind of what we would
expect let's just watch this again and
see what we get all right cool there we
go so that's kind of that's nice to have
obviously right now we're just hot
coding it in the shader which isn't good
because it means every texture will be
kind of tiled ten times which isn't
exactly what we want but then the other
thing that I was talking about was
adding a color which you can also do
really easily if I just basically
multiply these with a color so for
example I want to tint it red I won't
change the red Channel at all but then
like the other two channels for example
I will reduce and I'll keep the Alpha at
one point zero like this then what I'll
actually get here is a slightly red
tinted checkerboard texture and you can
see it here so there's a number of cool
things you can do this tiling kind of
factor here could be added as a uniform
and circulate this color so if you want
to kind of experiment with that stuff
until I make that next episode then go
ahead and do that it's a great learning
exercise to kind of make this a little
bit more flexible a little bit more
powerful and I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please hit that
like button don't forget to help support
the series on patreon of course because
it would not be here without all those
generous people supporting this next
time I think we'll continue on without
to the render of a number of exciting
things to talk about which I'm not going
to reveal just yet I will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]